foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
okay
oh I'm running way behind I didn't even
make the the pre-show for yesterday like
because normally I like to have the show
from yesterday going like so we we know
what's going on uh people know when the
podcast is gonna go live but last night
none of that happened because it just I
already did r r and I knew that my girl
was not feeling that already so I wasn't
gonna try to like
lately
[Music]
all right there
what's going on
[Music]
thank you
oh we could talk about that
[Music]
I think that's good uh I try to keep
this fast in and out
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's going on guys I know I'm late no
one has to sit there no one has to put
it in the comments section add if you're
like I know this I'm very aware of how
late I am okay I had a lot of stuff
going on and Valentine's Day kind of
carried over today and you know I went
to see the grandparents and you know I
ain't seen them in probably a year since
my father passed away so I was over
there a little bit I was over there I
know I'm late only on Xbox I told you
man you guys don't listen
has that been athlete
yeah is that that's is that a compliment
I
have a compliment
very well for him so uh so as you guys
see uh dartsock could be here today he
had some uh stuff he had to attend to uh
so you know we'll catch him next week uh
but we got Plum Network you know I came
across this guy because you guys kept
bringing him up every time I bring up
you know I I looking for newer kind of
newer personalities brand IOP uh Plum
Network Plum Network get unplug Network
so I was all right so I reached out to
him uh funny enough kids will beat me to
him I don't know if kiss move was like
cheating on my my cheat sheet or
something of the people I wanted to come
on uh but he beat me to him and I I like
the energy that Plum brings into the
industry I feel like you know we ain't
had a a content creator so level-headed
in a while uh so play networks tell the
people uh tell the people a little bit
about yourself man what kind of games
you like
yeah man I appreciate you having me on
um this move did get me he caught me
right at the perfect time on a Saturday
morning where I just woken up I was
finishing my coffee and nothing to do
and he's like hey you want to come on so
I was like sure whatever so that was
that was that was just perfect timing
for him but um yeah I I play like a ton
of stuff like I play RPGs first person
shooters right now I'm playing uh
Hogwarts Legacy which I'm finding just
absolutely phenomenal and also playing
Fire Emblem and Gage on on the Nintendo
switch so I beat that that was a good
game
yeah I'm slowly going through it I'm
only on like chapter 10 right now but I
am enjoying it I like the uh the
cutscenes and the story going on so far
um and it's Fire Emblem I mean the
gameplay in Fire Emblem you like it
you'll enjoy the game
um but yeah play a variety of stuff and
uh like you said I try to keep
level-headed talking about gaming news
and everything so yeah appreciate you
having me on sorry sorry to the chat
that I'm not dirt right now I saw again
give me death so uh it's like I said uh
you know they just like the band for me
I mean you know me uh iops a little bit
more corporate you know we try to keep
the uh the Fanboy out of it and you know
it's not saying that this is a fanboy
show it's just a little bit more like
Freedom like you know you can joke
around a little bit more uh you know we
try to keep that a little bit off IOP
because obviously you know we we want
that chat to be moderated you know my
chat is moderated but you know I do let
you guys be in a way of too much I'm
gonna say that I do let you guys get
away with too much sometimes I gotta
have faith in my mods and sometimes I
don't and I need to start being better
on that uh so definitely you know uh
plan that work I I like the the kind of
videos he gives out like the the energy
gives out you know I definitely wanted
to bring them in here you know pick his
mind a little bit on the stuff that we
talking about uh so you know first thing
I want to talk about that I've seen
going around is um
this game pass hurting
uh Game Pass hurting cells uh you know I
think
for the longest time we've seen this and
we've seen uh this kind of narrative uh
we've seen a lot of people talk about
stuff like this you know
I want your overall opinion like you
know of you do you personally feel like
Game Pass does contribute to hurting
cells in some way shape or form
I I think it's like very dependent on
the title the game itself and everything
I think logically
if you think about it for Xbox first
party games there's obviously going to
be
um a ton of people who are deciding not
to go out and buy the game on Xbox
because it's it's within Xbox game pass
and that makes complete sense why would
you why would you go buy it when it's in
there day and date but then we've also
seen like stuff with like Forza Horizon
and even Halo infant when they both
release day day and date and Game Pass
how well they sold on Steam so I think
there it will affect sales a little bit
it'll cannibalize it a little bit but
overall for Xbox as a business it makes
sense to cannibalize some of those sales
to get more people into your into the
Xbox ecosystem so that they are spending
more money and all their attention is
within Xbox in terms of like third-party
games I would I would say we've seen
examples of games that have come out on
in Game Pass and still sold a very well
especially if they're multi-platform and
we've seen developers and Publishers say
that they've they've liked the success
of their games Within game pass and
there's definitely examples of where
Game Pass is actually boosted sales I
mean one of the ones people always talk
about is uh the descenders and the no
more robots uh the development Studio
where they were saying that they did
their numbers pre and post game pass and
they were like way more sales after they
had put their games into the game pass I
think it's like very dependent on style
of game I don't think it's just a it's
good or it's a bad thing overall I think
Game Pass is a net positive on on the
gaming industry and for developers and
publishers
yeah it seems like we're having a little
uh it seems like YouTube's bugging a
little bit in terms of uh the stream
hopefully it'll it'll settle out keep me
updated on that guys if it starts to
settle out sometimes YouTube be working
just fine for months I've not had issues
with streaming but the moment I bring a
new guest on we're gonna have all the
issues in the world yeah I agree with
you I feel like you know
they are games that it will ball it will
hurt obviously you know look at
something like Starfield
you're going to realistically have
people that would have bought that game
but they have a subscription so why
would you do it and you know Microsoft
is giving you that option if you don't
want to go out there and support to that
degree you can go ahead and pick up the
game on the subscription service you
don't have to worry about stuff like
that so I definitely understand that the
biggest thing I would actually say is
you know do you think let's say that
because I was talking to kids smooth
about this and
do you honestly feel that we've got to
the point because I do truly believe
that game pass was originated because
Microsoft was having a hard time
bouncing back from the Xbox one
generation and they were trying to find
more unique ways of monetizing their
games that didn't put themselves in in a
disadvantage you know what I'm saying
and I think that's why Game Pass
originated now if these games start
delivering how they're supposed to if
Starfield comes out and it's good and
Hellboy comes out and it's good and you
know we get good results from stuff like
a vowed do you think that if they start
seeing a huge return and they don't see
game passes uh numbers going up as much
as they want do you think that they
could not necessarily hit the reverse
car because we know if they get rate of
Game Pass it's going to be issues it's
going to be a lot of bad public uh
publicity uh but do you think if they
take that bad publicity if something
like that ever happened and they have
these games do you think that they can
get their people to go back to paying
for those those games at a full price as
long as they're good
I think I think that would be really
really tough from from a marketing and
PR person oh it would it would be almost
impossible I think it would be almost
impossible yeah I think there would be a
ton of backlash and yeah I'm sure some
people would go back like I would go and
buy Star field if they said it's not
coming to Game Pass they went I would go
out and buy it and and play it if it was
the only choice I had but I think for
I think for a large majority of people
they would they would just switch
platforms or they would they would
revolt against that decision because
like that was the main selling point of
Game Pass was first party games day and
date into the service and if that's not
there people would be like well right
now
PlayStation has exclusives coming out
want to play Spider-Man I want to play
uh they want to play God of War Ragnarok
all these games why not just go back
over to PlayStation and then sign up for
PlayStation Plus because their their
service there is still relatively decent
they just don't have the first party
game so I think that the big selling
point is first party
uh and more people would probably just
go and buy it go buy it on Steam so I
think it's I think honestly it's too
late for them to do that it would be
it'd be a bad move I I do feel like it
would be very hard to navigate those
Waters but I do feel like if they had
the games if they hit the reverse card
which I'm not saying they're going to
they're never going to do that but I do
think it's a conversation worth having
because you know
I personally feel like the Microsoft now
and the Microsoft back when they
originated Game Pass two different
microsofts now and you know I'm very
curious if you know they could hit that
button and take back Game Pass or even
you know maybe not have it day in day in
games coming out that I wonder if
quality games would make people
obviously they're still going to
complain I'm gonna go plane uh people
are still gonna complain but
we've seen it over and over again with
certain things and you know uh political
stands on certain games and you know uh
cancel culture going a different array
like
all that's cute but when it comes to a
good game being a good game
is people going to not do it because the
Game Pass isn't on it to me I feel like
they would have a huge Rock Foundation
they would be going through some Muddy
Waters but if they deliver the content
people are gonna go and get it
yeah I agree I think like like a game
like Starfield and even redfall if it's
if it delivers on what we're expecting
it to be people would still go out and
pay for it and play it I just think that
there would be too much of an like a
negative effect on people's perception
of Xbox or right now you look at Xbox
and they've done a really really good
job from turning the narrative away from
the Xbox one generation to where they
are now and then doing a move like that
would completely reverse it so but
people I like I agree like a game like
Starfield people are gonna buy anyway so
we're gonna see Star field sales on
Steam
um and on just on PC in general they're
going to be huge even even though it's
in game pass on day one still gonna see
people going out and buying it I do
think that there are uh scenarios that
actually do help game uh help numbers of
Game Pass first party Xbox they're
taking the L there's just nothing you
could do about that when you offer this
game day in day
people can you know people could say
they just use Game Pass to validate they
want to buy the game that's cat very few
people do that you know if if the game
goes into game past day and day I would
be very curious how many of those people
actually buy the game probably a very
small number the majority of people
they're going to play the service on
that service and I don't blame them
because uh you know Netflix uh people
don't sit there and watch two episodes
of stranger things say y'all go get it
when it comes to DVD
no they I'm gonna watch the whole thing
on the service I pay subscription
service for uh so but when it comes to
Indie games like um you know death door
when those games leave Game Pass I could
see you know because they got so many
people eyeing on them it could help uh
multi-platz when a game like outriders
came out in Game Pass and it's getting
all this attention you see people say yo
why don't you play I can't play it it's
it's in Game Pass well you could play
you just gotta buy it there's gonna be
people seeing their XBox friends playing
stuff they only got a PlayStation or
steam uh well unless it's not on PC game
pass they'll naturally buy it on those
other platforms because of the positive
inner the positive publicity that game
is getting would you think that was a
correct statement
yeah no I agree I think that's the
biggest thing that game pass does it
just gets games out there that people
wouldn't otherwise play or otherwise
heard of and it helps them take off I
mean we just saw the example of Hi-Fi
Rush with Shadow dropped and how well
that did launching day and Dayton in
Game Pass and then also
I think it was like it be forespoken
within the first week and it was like a
30 dollar game compared to a 70 game
people buying it on steam or something
like that so if it's a good game it will
sell and people will play it on Game
Pass either way yeah really how good the
content is that's how it's always been
through through the beginning of time
when it comes to games people will go
where the games are look obviously
it's not a hundred percent guaranteed
you know I I will say games like
the original uh uh Dead Rising Not Dead
Rising uh Dying Light I feel like that's
a one where people didn't show up how in
in the the groups that they should have
showed up I would say another example is
like Lost Odyssey blue dragon those are
fantastic Xbox games that didn't really
get a good reception they really should
have and it's sad that they didn't
didn't like these kind of games they
didn't get the
the love that I think they deserve but I
think there's more
to that than just sales obviously
turn-based games that's not Final
Fantasy has a hard time surviving in
those
um you know and this is back when Final
Fantasy was doing that they don't
necessarily do that anymore but I can
understand with some of these Niche
games just having a hard time to sell
and that's why I feel like those do
really well on Game Pass because you can
for instance jrpgs
do a hard time on Xbox because this the
fan base hasn't really had a line like a
direct Bloodline with that type of
titles for years so obviously if you're
not getting the good ones the ones that
are popular the ones that are popping
when the newer ones come out you don't
buy those why does people care Final
Fantasy you know uh crisis scores on the
Xbox when you can't get the games it's
leading up to
so there's no real reason to invest into
that franchise on the Xbox brand because
you're not even really into that
franchise because you don't get them
yeah it's like same with like Persona
too and I wonder how well those actually
did on Game Pass and how many people
jumped in and played those but I would
argue that like I agree with you that
you don't get them so people don't care
as much but that's that's the issue that
Xbox needs to work on is getting those
games because it's not like people on
Xbox won't play them they will they just
never really a lot of people if they've
played Xbox their entire life haven't
been introduced to them if it's the only
thing that they're playing and that's
why I feel like Game Pass is really
vital in those veins because you get
something like Persona 5. nine times out
of ten you have a lot of old heads that
that played the old Final Fantasy games
you know play octopath travel they love
those type of games but you know they
their mindset is I gotta play those
platforms to get those but keep in mind
there's probably a lot of people that
used to play turn-based games back in
the 90s and early 2000s they don't play
them anymore because they're on Xbox uh
Lost Odyssey I would say that's just as
good as almost every old style final
Fantasy game and if they remade that
I feel like it would sell well you know
I think yeah the problem is
J good jrpgs do so well on any platform
it's just when you have the overall mind
of people that are buying PlayStations
to play those type of platforms when you
do have an Xbox you just automatically
think I'm gonna play it on Playstation
you have all these multi-console owners
that they have both
but they already play those they when
they think of Final Fantasy even though
crisis scores out on the Xbox and you
have all these people that have both and
they're like okay crisis course coming
out why would they buy it on place on
Xbox at that time they have them on both
they play all those games on plays that
you're gonna naturally see a a shift in
people playing that because it's on the
PlayStation on Xbox
yeah why my like my question now right
is with square talking about screenings
it's like octopath traveler came out on
Nintendo switch and then it came out on
Xbox and Xbox game pass later and now
octopath traveler 2 isn't on Xbox only
on PlayStation and Nintendo so I wonder
if there are some like numbers there
that the square inch is looking at and
not wanting to put it on Xbox or if
there's some some backroom deal because
I think they're pretty bad
yeah maybe but like why would I what I
don't understand is with who because
it's on it's on the switch and it's on
Playstation so they're just like we
don't want it on Xbox I think it's the
same thing you saw when it come to like
Ori in the blind Forest it came on
switch Xbox not PlayStation I think
PlayStation and Xbox have like these
low-key deals where it's like okay you
know
they they make these deals with the
second and third party people they don't
own and they're like look what are you
gonna pay for to make this exclusive
well I can give you this much for an
exclusivity or I give you this much you
could put it on everywhere but
PlayStation and I think PlayStation does
the same thing you know uh there's but
the difference is I've seen mainly
Xbox do it on Indie titles there's
definitely a reason that something like
uh death door didn't come out on
Playstation first or at the same time it
came out later because Microsoft made
that deal look we're going to help you
fund this game we're going to give you
more money to put it in Game Pass it
makes zero sense why they wouldn't put
that on Playstation if they could have
it's a bigger platform could have made a
lot of money on that platform the only
logical thing that makes sense is there
was a deal put in place preventing it
from going on that platform
yeah no I I guess that it's just a weird
it's a weird thing the Xbox and square
relationship that's always changing
every time a new title comes out whether
you're always guessing whether it's
going to be on Xbox or not or what if
all Final Fantasy games came to Game
Pass and now Final Fantasy 16 isn't on
Xbox so it's just it's a weird thing and
I feel like
how much money is are they paying to do
that and is it truly worth it for Square
Enix to do it it must be because they do
it all the time so
yeah
I I guess to me you know I'm a big
person out at these days where I'm never
going to tell you not to buy something
you know if you are generally curious
about the Final Fantasy brand by Crisis
Core uh completely 100 on uh understand
that especially if you want to if you
feel like I just don't want to make
people under the impression that's
supporting a game oh Cricket he's coming
I don't want people to have the
impression that just because you support
it means it's going to happen because I
don't think that's the case I I don't
think that even if Final Fantasy Crisis
course sold well I don't want people
thinking that's going to result in more
of the franchise coming into the
platform because I don't think that's
the case and uh you know cut stuff like
that it's just like come on man like
just choose one side or the other are
you gonna let the games come to Xbox or
not because to me yeah having Crisis
Core on It come on Xbox and nothing else
is kind of a spit in the face we're
going to give you the prequel nothing
after and to me that I don't know about
you dirt but to me that is low-key
promoting like I'm subconsciously
promoting the Final Fantasy VII remakes
because it's like oh this is cool man
this universe is lit when's the next one
coming out oh you need a PlayStation for
that
what's going on dirt
what's happening fellas how you doing
how do I sign off I don't care
okay cool what's up man
what's up bro
do good man how you doing I'm doing good
man I'm doing good he came in here and
was like oh we gotta guess let me pop in
here real quick
nine bro like you like you were usually
hit me up early in the day yeah it's
just been crazy man and like usually
when you don't hit me up I don't think
we're gonna have a show so I was doing
stuff just found out I've been paying
for super fast internet for two years
but wasn't using it because I had an out
of date router uh modem I'm sorry so I'm
like what
so I've been paying for this for two
years and had an out of date modem so I
was doing that uh so when you text me so
yeah I'm here now so
yeah thank you I mean you didn't really
miss much uh the thing we were talking
about is you know there's been a lot of
report coming out on the Xbox camp that
maybe game passes cannibalizing their
own cells you know we I remember a
couple years ago we were told by like
people like Phil Spencer that that's not
the case and I I think people misquote
him all the time
um people misquoted him back in the the
breath of the wild days where he said
they uh that those games didn't do as
well as they were and they're not as
relevant as they used to be he never
said those games are trash and no one
wants to play them he said in terms of
the the popularity of those games sure
you have some that succeed but those are
the outliners not the rule you know what
happens when people talk about oh we
talk about breath of wild let's talk
about the shadow mortal franchise
there's plenty of other stuff people
want to talk about the higher Echelon of
single player games to succeed but don't
talk about none of this garbage is down
here that don't go anywhere like right
it's just like but what's everyone talk
about fortnite Apex Legends Call of Duty
Warzone that's what Phil Spencer was
saying he was saying it was going to
that direction but what I want to ask
you dirt is when it comes to do you
truly think that there is some form of
uh some form of capitalization going on
thank you
well um I think only a dummy would think
the Xbox game pass wouldn't affect sales
I mean because if you have uh this
person here say oh I can pay 70 for the
game or I can just play it in this
Subscription Service I mean most people
would say I will play in the
subscription service so I mean I'm sure
it does a little bit but everybody knew
that I know what you said Xbox said
years ago but what type of games was he
tough like what they're talking about
said some people buy more games because
of Game Pass were you talking about
indie games because we saw the guy Mike
Rose that's what I'm saying they
misquote them he was talking about games
that don't normally get a lot of shine
or getting massive success over
absolutely man and I think that's yeah I
mean bro it's it's simple when Field
Spencer speaks you know uh people
misquote them intentionally to fit their
narratives I think it's simple yet only
a phone with yes of course Xbox game
pass hurt game sales if a specific game
okay
upcoming game atomic heart right on Xbox
I'm sure it's going to sell more on
Playstation not just because PlayStation
has a bigger install base but because
atomic heart drops in Game Pass day one
on Xbox of course it's going to hurt the
sales on Xbox
yeah duh so yes I mean it's it's
beautiful to me it's the discussion
isn't like it doesn't really matter but
the sales being cannibalized at the end
of the day is how much revenue are these
developers and Publishers making right
I'm sure they're selling less units but
they're getting a huge amount of money
up front which offsets those units
they're not going to sell and they don't
have to worry about marketing as much
they don't have to worry about losing
development costs with that risk and
that's I think far more important for
the for the devs than losing out of some
sales on Xbox because they're playing it
through Game Pass absolutely not to
mention
what we see is all they're not getting
those those cells and what developers
and Publishers seeing is there's more
ways for us to monetize our games
besides sales we can see here and go six
months off the raw cells and then after
six months we can pop over here to
Microsoft like yo give me that bag I'll
drop this in Game Pass for a couple
months and then that after that they can
go to Sony yo give me that give me that
bag I'll drop this off in your
PlayStation Plus or whatever the hell it
is there's more Avenues of them to make
money in general
I agree and like there's games like
let's be honest there's games that I
played in Xbox game pass that I would
not have bought
I said oh this game looks interesting
I'm going to check it out it was a game
called roll 96 I played that enjoyed it
I wouldn't I wouldn't have bought that
game you know so there's so many titles
that's similar to that
that Xbox game pass is actually um um
you know
putting their game out there more for
people to give it a chance you know
they're not they won't spend 30 40 50
for it but maybe they'll try an Xbox
game pass say damn you know what I love
this game it's pretty good and you know
and then not to mention like you see
stuff where I'm convinced like put the
old shovel knights in there you know
when the next Shovel Knight comes out if
it's not in Game Pass you're gonna
naturally have better sales because
people was I think it is in Game Pass
the next one the next one is but you get
what I'm saying like yeah yeah Persona
five four and three in there uh you know
you can't convince me that Persona 6 if
it's on Xbox isn't going to sell better
because the previous ones was more
accessible to the Xbox Community exactly
the fan base like the Judgment games the
Yakuza games those games were not even
on Xbox in the past
um but since Xbox made a deal with Sega
they put the games in Game Pass that's a
whole franchise that people that's
that's Xbox players didn't even really
know about then I actually tried out the
Judgment games those games are awesome
absolutely amazing games so that's
something I never tried until they put
the Yakuza games and Xbox game pass and
then plus you got to look at it from
this too you know you're never gonna
really know what kind of you know Middle
Ground was actually gonna buy that game
if it wasn't in game pass because at the
end of the day
you know there's a lot of games that
people weren't gonna buy anyway you know
they they were only willing to try
because it was in Game Pass for instance
it shows a lot of people that starfo
doesn't look like their type of game
redfall doesn't look like their type of
game they were never gonna buy that game
but now they have access to it uh sure
you know does it cut into sales apps uh
hell I wanted to say the F4 but I'm
trying not to cut absolutely uh there is
definitely a huge amount of people that
would have bought Starfield if it wasn't
in Game Pass but guess what Microsoft
wants it that way they want you to be in
that Subscription Service like I said
earlier they're like no one
No One's Gonna wait for stranger things
to come on DVD in the in Walmart they're
gonna watch it there and then if you got
the the tryhards they're gonna go that's
why I think that they're doing this uh
you know they've been doing for a while
now where it's like look you want in
Game Pass you can wait in Gamepad but if
you want to play three days early you're
gonna have to buy that sucker like and
the sad part is when it comes to like
People Like Us content creators damn
like this
we saw that with Forza Horizon 5 with
the three days early right that's sold
like crazy I mean so like crazy yep yeah
and I and like the thing with game pass
is it's all about the attention that's
what they want they want people's
attention in their ecosystem and that's
why they put all these games that would
have never played but that's like
another 10 hours that your attention is
within Xbox that could have been on
another platform so that's why it's I
think extremely powerful as a service
and we look at all like the game the
free to play games the games as a
service in the last month or so that
just shut down because there's so many
out there yeah and they're all just
competing for attention they're Xbox
they keep putting all these games in
here and sure it'll cannibalize some
sales but it'll keep people's attention
in their ecosystem and these games that
would people are discovering that they
would have never played so I think
there's like a win-win we even look at
like Guardians of the Galaxy when that
dropped in Game Pass you vitalized that
game so yep that's just way more
positive for Game Pass and there's
negative and there's always that
narrative trying to like trying to
destroy Game Pass that's bad for the
game you know it's crazy I can
understand like like you as a stock
owner or or something like that you
invested in the company use a huge
investor not like you bought two shares
and you're concerned about Game Pass
hurting your your returns next year but
major people invested I can understand
one of them came out yo I'm concerned
that the sales for Starfield could have
been way better if Game Pass wasn't
around but you got these people
literally wanting to pay more money to
the game like literally like I want to
support the developer sorry bro you
ain't supporting the developer even if
you buy the game because we've seen Time
After Time games still sell well they
don't get a sequel games sell well and
they still get laid off
so at the end of the day you know that's
why I always say
when it comes to certain games I will
tell you right now like
um you know what's the game uh
cholesterol protocol I told people not I
tell people I think it's an okay game
they missed a lot of notes but if you
want to get out and you want to actually
come out there and support a company
that's trying something like that
because a lot of that type of
quality even though there's a lot of
issues it's not an easy feat for the
type of Studio that they was it's kind
of like equivalence like Ninja Theory
you know they they are making hot they
were punching way above than they
actually realistically should have been
punching for their for their weight
class I was like if you got the extra
money rolling around you do want to have
a decent experience support the game
because I want to see the studio get
another chance
absolutely and see like I love love that
game the Calista protocol I would love
to see a sequel not quite sure is going
to happen
you know because you know it didn't sell
as well as they thought it should have
but you know
put it in Game Pass
yeah
that will put a lot of more eyes on that
game you can only buy it yeah more
people may buy it too after they've
played it in Game Pass so yep so uh two
dollars from Stanley the problem is Xbox
games
XBox guys saying Sony should do it I
don't
I don't think that they necessarily
think the Sony should do it I just think
that look if you have the best food in
the world and you getting it pretty
cheap well I wouldn't say best food you
got some good food you get a pretty
cheap man when you want the other people
doing it too
you know just because I go one place and
he don't mean I don't want all of them I
want all of them to be the same damn
price all right and you know obviously
there's people using their own motives
but to me as a consumer and as a gamer I
want everybody to have a subscription
service I want I want
um I'm on Nintendo to let me play these
games for a monthly subscription service
I want Sony to let me do it I want Xbox
to let me do it like to me there is zero
reason for you not to want them to do it
unless you're an investor you're
generally concerned that it's going to
hurt your returns
yeah
listen I think this guy I don't know I'm
assuming he's a PlayStation guy because
why would he say this I don't think XBox
guys are saying Sony should do it some
of us say we think that Sony will do it
because you know Xbox game pass has
about 30 million subscribers I think if
Sony put their games in the service then
they they will probably surpass Xbox
game pass eventually because you know of
you know just like the content that they
have maybe but at the same time you guys
bash Xbox game pass and always saying yo
Sony will probably do it too so let me
ask you a question oh sorry go ahead uh
no I was gonna say Sony
kind of did it today when they dropped
Horizon in PlayStation plus it's only
been what a year right yeah it's been
yeah it's only been here well forbidden
West is in PlayStation Plus yeah they're
driving me this money that's kind of
crazy that's really soon I didn't know I
haven't been paying attention for stuff
like that because uh yeah it's just been
crazy uh we got a 10 super chat for men
uh Mandingo mcdick oh man I can see is
that what how do you pronounce your name
they clown in me man man Mandingo make
Dickens no I'm talking about Plum
Network how you pronounce it it's plume
plume okay yes they clowning me so plume
uh I can see uh attic and plune though I
hear it though oh my God so I hear it
I'll read this at it I'll read it
I can see attic and plume though I hear
a third person
I just see nothing but Darkness on the
bottom half of the screen he makes the
black hole look light skin great show
fellas how dare you Mandingo damn it
this is I don't I don't even know if I'm
allowed to react to this man don't worry
let's just move one pos man Bingo how
dare you I'm on the show with a couple
white guys you can't be saying stuff
like that
foreign
okay plume yeah I can't believe I was
mispronouncing this man's thing I did
the same thing when he was on wbza I
think everyone I think everyone
mispronounced that first I just don't
correct him because I'm like whatever
correct people
people misspelled my name it's the first
thing I do my name is I spelled with an
I spelled with an E You Know It uh Paris
does it well he doesn't like people uh
spelling his name uh you know how Paris
is spelled he has an extra eye I think
and you know at first I used to like
dude it's not that big of a deal just
tell me if you're coming on the show or
not like because I used to spell them
but you know at the end it's like I get
it you know you go your whole life
people always misspelling your name uh
it's like at that point it's like dude
just change your name to one eye like
yes uh five dollars Super Chat from Jess
uh cheese I don't know I would ciao I
would challenge how's the food argument
there are uh there is a person like
Little Caesars is cheaper than real life
there's a reason Little Caesars is
cheaper I get that I feel you on that I
get that but you know
I don't eat Little Caesars actually I I
because they might have cheaper pizza
but you could tell the quality and the
food look
excuse me look I'm from Michigan Right
Detroit where Little Caesars originated
the five hot the five dollar hide and
ready
yes it might not be the best qualities
not as good as you know some of the
other pizza places
but
that five dollar hot and ready benefited
tons of families oh yeah
and tons of families man
and they also have better Pizza there
like not just to find out hot and ready
it's just that basic five dollar hot and
ready benefited tons of families I I've
seen it with my own eyes yeah so let me
get this uh this patreon question real
quick it says Hey Lords I wanted to get
your opinion on this do you think that
Forza Motorsports will release on
October with Xbox x and S bundle and
then for the holiday kickoff we s uh we
get star filled in November with its own
Xbox x and x console to rival Spider-Man
2 launch thanks to them have a great
week can't wait to uh to see I can't
wait for this week's podcast William I
appreciate William Riggs yeah I
appreciate that uh so what do you guys
think you think they're gonna have
bundles I think star I think I think
this holiday is too late for for Star
Phil but you guys what do you guys think
yeah no I think like they'll just do
like the marketing thing with the game
pass and then like have star fill in the
Box I don't think they would like
include
a full download code for it
well
yeah I think
no yeah like I agree like it's too late
in the fall to do that unless it comes
out in the fall but yeah I could see a
star filled custom series X yeah that's
what I was about to say I believe
Starfield is that big of a game
but there's this first new IP in years
it's a huge game it's Xbox biggest games
it's one of the biggest games this year
period
I can see them doing a custom console
awesome controller and a bundle
uh X by series X bundle because I think
it's just a big game for them this year
now if we go excuse me if it comes out
in June
I still think you know
that
with the five how dare you make Dickens
I thought I'd be I thought I was I was
the only one to roast dirt on on someone
else podcast what's up dirt brother
Darkness what's up e-man you POS hey
these guys
at least the homies they'll be on my
show talking trash and all day on your
show addict talking trash it's it's
funny they they going back and forth I'm
surprised mcthickins joined it on the on
the uh the the little inside jokes
trust me he's always there on wbg and
TTS every week but you know they're the
homies it's all out of love and so when
it comes to Forza I I don't think you'll
see a um
you're gonna see like a custom I don't
know Force has gotten pretty big they
might do a custom thing or it's a
motorsport yeah I remember they did uh
Forza six they did a custom console
custom controller because I bought the
controller
seven they didn't I don't think Forza
will have a custom console not this year
with Starfield coming out no
he'll be wrong oh but I don't I don't
think so
yeah I think that
they could surprise us have a custom
console for both yeah that would be huge
and you know I honestly feel like you're
looking at
the next three months star food will be
out
I think the next three months star food
will be up uh because I I do think that
they are pushing for a hellblade holiday
launch I love that
'd be massive yeah that would be huge
magic kind of year that is you know
Hi-Fi Rush going into Minecraft Legends
then then
Forza then Starfield and then hellblade
to end it off that's that's that's a
pretty good year that's a pretty nice
year yeah that's crazy but but they
gotta follow it up and I know getting
ahead of ourselves but they got to
follow that up in 2024 which luckily
they have all these IPS that they're
going to be able to absolutely we're
starting to see like the consistency
yeah if this year delivers we're
starting to see what 23 and potentially
plus Activision Studios is going to be
delivering on Xbox I told you I agree uh
you know Dirk we've been talking about
for a while
Sony has a certain amount of time
to respond to Game Pass and all these
Studios they bought before Microsoft
gets to the point where they're delaying
stuff because it's done but they just
can't overlap their other games right
you know yeah look at all the studios
that you know we know where some of them
are you know even though that leak was
misleading they still said they expect
Fable in 2024. I think beginning of 2025
I think that's more realistic approach
uh but even that gear six been on
development for probably a year year and
a half you know because even though we
got that information you know that's old
right we find out stuff long before it
happens uh Coalition you know they're a
good Studio compulsion they've been
they've been cooking for like six years
yeah they've been making yeah because uh
we happy if you came out of 2018 yeah
Exile entertainment they've made
Wasteland a few years ago they're
probably going to be releasing games
there that around that time then you got
Perfect Dark probably you're probably
gonna do something around that time then
you got a valve out of the world too
right and I was told out of worlds two
is actually more in development than
people think so it's like you look at
these and then what you know what's
funny guys when all those games come out
then you're going to have the first
people that launch games their games are
ready to come back right it's going to
be a Hey listen it's gonna be
uh consistent flow of games right I know
2022 was a year that we didn't have any
right you know we like damn this it's a
dry year but you know I think it's
pretty clear that Xbox had to make that
sacrifice we have to you know deal with
it as Xbox fans no no trip no big AAA
first party titles but 2023 moving
forward I don't think that's going to be
an issue anymore
I don't
I don't know what this is about I've
never
now when I go to like mod people because
I modded you uh plum
it says managing moderator have you seen
that there what the hell is a managing
moderator never heard of a managing
model because now there's a ad is a
standard moderator and AD is a managing
moderator I'm curious what that means is
it like they give the the same rights
that I have as a channel owner I have no
idea because what's funny is like the
only people that the Mars can't hurts me
you know I I overrule y'all yo I go
there I can go in there and say so much
stuff about flame and be like what you
gonna do you want to just leave the
podcast
uh it's kind of it's kind of crazy let's
let's go and move on man you know we did
it is Eric the Beer Guy man you oh boy
if he was on my channel man you'll be
gone so we've been sniped you so quick
uh these guys I don't understand these
guys just come to Xbox podcast and this
this has nothing to say except well yeah
Xbox losing in sales oh Xbox ain't got
nothing but cartoon games like these are
guys I can't stand man yeah so all right
let's talk about Hogwarts Legacy
um who hears Plato
let me know just a little bit I haven't
played it yet I did the character
creation I wish it was amazing by the
way yeah you know I guess I've never
really cared about like character
customization
um most of the games I play I have a
helmet on never see myself I literally
usually go with the default I don't even
miss the most of the time uh but I can
honestly say coming from like a white
dude if I wanted to make myself
I could make myself an 80 Game Boy all
right so I couldn't imagine what it's
like to like
want to make yourself and they're like
yo well I guess there ain't no black
people making the the anything in this
game so there's no yeah I feel like
there's got to be like us like a
a studio needs to literally be designed
and I think they make money dirt where
it's like they're they're well
versatized in multiple engines and you
could hire them to make the character
customization for a variety of different
people
um hold on like so you're saying a
studio specifically for that for and
it's not just
like you could do a variety of different
styles like I think they'll get cleaning
your work
instead of doing that it's like just
outsources to them people man they like
that yeah especially you know black
people they complain about it because
it's valid so it's just like you know
they hear it you know they get annoyed
that other people are annoyed about it
dude it's just like what's funny is I
talk to a developer and he said because
I asked him I was like dude why don't
you ever do right by by you know black
hairstyle it's like dude some of those
are hard to do yeah it was like you
wouldn't believe the amount of stuff
that is is is hard because let's be real
here man I got a receding hairline
there's they're like white people got
pretty much the same hairstyles like
like dude every time I watch a new thing
that's made by um uh 50 Cent like a new
show it's the new hairstyle you've ever
seen before like
so I get what they're coming from on
their end it's like you know especially
a lot of a lot of uh black women's hairs
like crazy so it would be hard to like
make that but just like if someone made
a studio
and it was they were experts at that
imagine what it was like for that studio
I I have a hard time believing everyone
wouldn't hire them
just so they don't have to worry about
that
yeah like I said they would get plenty
of work but Hogwarts is the first game I
can remember in a long time that
that got the black hair right
you know like for the most part the
female hairstyles the male hairstyles
they got it looking good
and I haven't um like gotten into it too
much because I still been um
I beat Dead Space remake right loved it
and I love it so much it made me want to
go play dead space too right and
I went back to play Dead Space 2 and
that's one thing I love about the Xbox I
played it f FPS boost HDR say wow and it
looks pretty good you know it's a 360
game obviously and uh yeah I love that
man so yeah that's that's why I didn't
really start playing Hogwarts yet
because I wanted to play dead space too
that I'm going to probably play three
like I love the Remake so much it made
me want to play the previous
game so I think you guys will enjoy it I
honestly do yeah Hogwarts so I figure
out what I played of it man well what's
your what's your opinion cologne you
know you how much time have you been
able to put in Hogwarts I have about
like
eight to ten hours in it so far
with you yeah it's not like a crazy
amount but like I'm going through it
slowly just like taking in everything
and I'm not like that I used to be a
Harry Potter fan like when I was younger
but I haven't followed it in a while but
man the detail in the game is just is
incredible and like
every every like hallway you're walking
through is just it's so well done and
even the combat when you're getting into
like the more of the dungeon areas and
you're taking on a bunch of enemies I
thought the combat was gonna be clunky I
thought it was going to be slow I'm like
how I wonder how cool can combat be with
a wand right like
very surprisingly good surprisingly good
surprisingly good and like you have to
really think about like your moves that
you're using on the enemies and but the
different colors that they that pop up
on them and when you have to block and
Dodge and everything so I think it's uh
I think it's phenomenal so far from what
I've played but like I said eight to ten
hours so far
you know the crazy part is uh let me
find out who made the studio because I I
was seeing the stuff they worked on
before it's not a lot Avalanche I think
the last game was like what Chicken
Little or something Chicken Little yeah
I think they made a chicken little game
Avalanche software uh yeah which is not
the same as Avalanche um that did the
just cause franchise you know what's
funny I saw
uh Tim Dog loved Tim Dog to death but I
saw him say like kind of like given the
illusion that they're the same company
and then when I was about to hit him up
like yo you know you got this wrong
um when I clicked the tweet it was
already gone yeah
stand up uh you know they
they do like Disney Infinity
yeah so they'd only be like kid games
but you know this goes to show you guys
like this how I feel
some of the teams we see do smaller
Kitty games sometimes they're talented
but that but like sometimes that's what
they have to do you know they have to do
what they have to do but you give those
guys a little extra budget add a couple
more people to the team yeah on time
because we know when it comes to
development time and budget is the two
most important things
you give those guys both of those things
and you see what happens boom this team
Avalanche they're killing me man this is
ridiculous let me read you some of these
uh games they've read they've been
around since 1996 first off wow that's a
long time they started out with Ultimate
Mortal Kombat 3 for uh Sega Genesis
Super Nintendo
um yeah then they did Mortal Kombat
Trilogy two on two open Ice Challenge I
don't know what the hell that I remember
that uh Rampage two Rampage Through Time
Rugrats in Paris the movie
wow I actually saw that movie yeah they
they did the GameCube and PS2 version uh
it looks like tack tack two
Dragon Ball Z Sagas Chicken Little
25 to life
Chicken Little
um remember 25 alive meet the the
Robertsons
Hannah Montana's Spotlight World Tour
wow Toy Story 3
Cars 2 Disney Infinity for like five six
years there's like five different
varieties of them uh cars three with the
last game they made was Cars 3 in 2017
and now Hogwarts Legacy
Bravo man Bravo to them
yep
Chicken Little doesn't look too bad
and to me at this point if WB isn't
looking at the studio and was like
give them more money give them more
Talent yeah we we are going to build
this studio out uh because we have
severely been underestimating you yeah
and they and they delayed the game
properly they yeah they put off the PS4
well they delayed the whole thing but
then they put off PS4 and Xbox One
versions
and the switch Eric the beer be getting
on my nerves but he said pretty sure you
just named off kids who's top 10 games
of all time yo as much as much as
be doing too much in that chat Eric that
was pretty funny I ain't cool a lot that
actually sounds something like kids
movie play oh man
yeah two dollar Super Chat from Apollo
Cooper listen uh the uh the Meet the
Robinsons game was fired I don't give a
[__]
bro listen but I I love to hear stories
like this you know they did a bunch of
kitty games they did games that they had
to do to make ends meet away you know
but now I gotta sneaks down
I'm sorry hold on yeah I I think this
studio is a prime example of you make a
good game people are going to show up
and yes I'm willing to bet you this is
the most money
wb's ever made in their gaming industry
bro easily I mean easily and this game
is killing it but like I said right
there there's like that is going to show
you that these teams
when they have talent man these
developers have talent you just have to
have the right time and budget and this
game is doing extremely well for WB and
kudos to Avalanche is Avalanche software
I mean software so like what's the name
uh Avalanche software yeah software yeah
shout out to them man and it says like
do you guys think that they go straight
to another Harry Potter IP or you think
they might try to let them do something
else no I'm thinking they're probably
gonna do another area Hogwarts Legacy
too or something because this is going
to cook for a while
yeah but but I'll say probably another
three or four years they're going to do
another one bro because uh this one is
doing extremely well for them
I got a uh someone said a Lord of the
Rings game could be just as successful I
actually like the Shadow of Mordor and
Shadow of War games yeah I thought that
was very good games very underrated they
did very good job with their lore
building WB for the most part have done
nothing but hit home runs
for the most part yeah I mean obviously
you got certain Batmans that didn't do
well I'm pretty sure suicide squad's
about to take a giant uh [__] on I think
it's Gonna Fly too I think it's Gonna
Fly I hope it doesn't but it just
doesn't uh two dollars from Apollo
Cooper time to drop that Microsoft bag
uh you know what's funny part of me the
only part of me that wanted this game to
not do as well was the part of me that
was like if Hogwarts Legacy and Suicide
Squad bomb
Microsoft can pull in the back and just
pick up that whole wall
that whole wire but you know I I I would
prefer to support well you know I think
I think the studio they made something
special and they deserved the
recognition and they deserve the sales
and I think they already sell 10 million
plus already yeah something like this
I know scoring is like oh why we can't
get sales like that maybe we need to
stop making everything exclusive to
PlayStation nah you got to stop making
good games people will show up if they
have good games it's not a fluke that
Eldon Rings sold as much as it did you
know why Odin ring sold it was a good
game God of War
good game you get cells and you make
good games the problem is is you have
too much of the industry Cloud chasing
off the the last Trend that was doing
well uh they they don't want to make any
original ideals they they feel like
they're not making Fortnight money
they're not being successful and I think
that's the biggest issue in the industry
um yeah well you know that's a great
point at it that's a great point I agree
with that damn
um hey let me say something to you
Michael it's only imagine so use it I
mentioned Suicide Squad and got them
nice I said listen guys got them nice is
that not that bad of a game
but who are these people I don't care
about these people the average gamer
doesn't care about Batgirl and no Robin
and all these nobody cares about them so
when I look at Suicide Squad even though
if the game like the game might be a
decent game
but nobody cares about a shark guy
Harley Quinn and these other nobody
cares about them and nobody wanted to
see evil Superman like nobody wants that
and I think those characters
not going to move the needle
best is my opinion on me I just don't
see it
and it might be a game that the service
which I don't mind games at the service
but in that type of game
we saw what happened to The Avengers
I don't know yeah and you know Plum I
got a question for you if if they would
have made the Avengers like a single
player uh action adventure that switched
between multiple Avengers and I had a
very compelling story and you know they
they could have still did the buy of the
microtransitions for certain uh outfits
outfits I don't think that would have
been the right move but they could have
done that if they wanted a little bit
more money I think that game would have
been way more successful what do you
think plum
yeah I mean absolutely I think that the
games of service is what killed it but
also like I don't know if you guys
remember seeing like some of the like
Spider-Man stuff that came out after
like how bad that looked like the
animations and just the overall gameplay
Avengers just didn't look like a good
game from the get-go just maybe it could
have done better but it just looked
Bland like the environments and
everything around it I had zero interest
in in checking Avengers and everything I
usually try out pretty much like I try
out tons of tons of games Avengers just
was never there for me I think I played
the demo and I was like uh
just a bland
crap I finished it I I finished it it
was okay
it was okay I mean like like it was okay
there was like a single player
experience or was it all just it was all
there was a single player experience but
um
it just didn't feel like it it didn't
feel linear enough to be just a single
player experience I it wasn't an open
world or anything like that it was just
you know all of these menus popping up
and you know they're trying to get you
to play co-op and this season and this
play this package over here play this
one over here it was just a little bit
too much a linear Avengers game would
have been quality made by Crystal
Dynamics because they're still a great
developer
just it just I don't know man it just
didn't hit right you know it just didn't
hit you know yeah I want I wonder if
suicide squad's gonna be like you guys
said if it's gonna go down the same I
really hope not in part let's go I was
gonna say these remind me of like a game
that was fun it was good to play in
gameplay but also failed and it was
games as a service like that was Anthem
like I wish that game would have been
able to come out and actually be a good
game and they could definitely do
something with that but I think it's
just like these styles of games they're
just all the same and people are just
you know their attention is on one and
they're they're playing that one game
yeah so when the same thing just keeps
coming out with a different skin they're
like well I'm just gonna go back yeah
you know that's a great point because I
always ask the question
um like PlayStation is making all of
these games as a service
um that's cool but who says they are
going to hit
right A lot of people just automatically
assume when this is PlayStation they're
gonna I think the Naughty Dog game has a
has a great possibility you know a
strong possibility that it's going to
hit because they're such a great
developer their name alone will get
people to give it a try
um but all those other ones who say
they're gonna hit man I mean
it's a gamble it's a gamble especially
when it's like you just mentioned
earlier all of these games that's that
that is recently you know shut down it's
the gambling if an apex Legends Mobile
isn't going to make it what makes it you
think that PlayStation games the service
again and like a bucks Legends mobiles a
very popular RP on phones that you don't
even need to buy any spend money on in
terms of a console and that didn't make
it so yeah and part of me
it's like if it does fail
I'm like so be it like it just at this
point with all these games the service
shutting down
um you know maybe these companies will
be like
maybe we were wrong maybe we should pull
back a little bit I feel like EA's
already got to that point they're like
definitely okay we were bugging all
right get that dude start making Dead
Space we gotta start reversing this
company they don't want to pay for games
weekly we get that now
they got to bring out Titanfall three
now
yeah
did you see that game they canceled
yeah I saw that and this morning in the
the TitanFall universe is supposed to be
like a like a character from Apex
legends that was like the main character
and they all was supposed to be in it
it's like you know I get it you know
they
they're getting as Jedi Survivor and
dead space this year so
right now they got my good graces you
know I think if anyone you know Square
Enix is on my [__] list you know they
they're the ones I would say Ubisoft is
eh I don't really care about their games
uh Nintendo I I like I like Sony's games
I wish Sony had better uh practices but
that's about all and Xbox needs to to
amp it up you know we need to see these
gains they've been making uh but you
know that's pretty much all we're going
to talk about when it comes to uh
Hogwarts Legacy I feel like there's
pretty much not a whole lot more we
could talk about that let's talk about
this then we'll go head out of here man
let's talk about
Starfield release date uh you know
there's been a lot of rumors on when
it's coming out where it's coming out if
it's coming out and
I'm I'm curious what your guys's opinion
is you know there were some rumors
that's coming out May saw some June some
July I think people are just throwing
months out there at this point uh I mean
at this point
the only reason they're not saying
January February and March is because
we're in those damn months so like uh
you know I'm curious what you guys think
you know what's your overall perspective
when starfield's coming out and when
would you want it to come out and when
do you think it's coming out we'll start
with uh Dart
well look man I'm gonna go Jazz court
and said he heard he heard June and for
me the ideal time would be
I don't know when E3 would be or Xbox
show is going to be but right before the
show I think would be perfect drop it a
week before the show
uh people still gonna be buzzing about
that and while they're buzzing about
Starfield
the Xbox is going to go out there and
announce some new stuff uh like three or
four new games that's that's uh that's
uh that's unannounced excuse me that's
unannounced I think that will be perfect
in my eyes
um
yeah so I'm thinking June I'm thinking
first
week of June
okay Plum what what's going on man
please please don't say anything past
June please please give me hope don't
don't extinguish it
yeah I know I'm going I'm going the end
of June I'm going like
I don't know June I think on like Gog
they have like the release date on
they're just placeholders like June 29th
I'm gonna go around that time I think
they're going to show it off at their
event their E3 slash naughty through
whatever you want to call it event and
they're gonna announce the date there
and it's going to be coming out like
right soon after that event but for me
like
personally like I think they gotta line
it up in in a time that's not
overlapping with a bunch of stuff when
is Forza Motorsport coming out that's
the question right yeah you don't want
those coming at all at the same time I'm
like all four I've said this before but
I'm like all four of them
if the game's ready
just you can delay it a couple of months
to put it in an open spot so it so you
don't have just a cram schedule because
it's a huge year and you got to
capitalize on all the games that are
gonna be coming out yeah
yeah so you know what when do you guys
want it to come out because thinking a
day that it might come out and your day
that you would prefer to come out things
to entirely differently no it's gonna
say shadow drop today let's be a little
realistic here what's that day man
what's that day
ah it's tough man there's so there's so
many games of 2023 I'm like my backlog
is huge and I'm a huge I'm super excited
for Starfield
but I would say like
I wanted to come out sometime in the
summer like June is fine like like
that's my prediction I think June's good
because when does redfall come out in
May yep yeah you'll have a good solid
month I say end of June like I predicted
because you have a good solid two months
right there to get into red Falls right
out and it's a different type of game
most people will probably have beaten it
by then and they'll be ready for
something new
and then if hellblade or something does
come out in 2023 you play Starfield go
hard on that until the holiday season
and then you can jump up to hell but
what about you though I'ma say I'm gonna
say specifically I'm looking at my
calendar right now I'm going to say June
9th which is a Friday I think that's the
Daystar field releases June 9th
um yeah and that's the day I wanted to
release also because like I said I'm
assuming Xbox
uh showcase or whatever because you know
it's probably going to be in June or
maybe be the 11th like since they
usually do
their shows on uh you know Sundays now
so that'll be a few days before that I
mean that seems perfect to me
like I said the buzz will still be
surrounding Starfield and then they're
going to have their show to Showcase
some more stuff in the future and people
want to be talking about Xbox so yeah
that's just me
uh so I got a 10 super shot from uh
dragba I probably butchered your name
man we're gonna be right past it though
uh good games sell well but good games
also get ignored all the time Avalanche
true they hit the jackpot and they
landed the Harry Potter IP enjoy the
ride but don't get mad if you folks
suggest you sold out
enjoy the ride but don't get mad if you
folks did you info suggest you solo Oh
so I see him like they're making a Harry
Potter yeah yeah but here's the thing uh
though the one thing I will push back on
that is it's everyone's dream to be able
to work in that kind of universe because
a you could still make the game your own
they clearly did and B
it's easier to sell and and have
longevity in your job because you're
working with something like the Harry
Potter IP and that's why I do believe
that that's the reason that they go this
direction uh you know we see it with
Star Wars all the time like right now
Jedi fallen or uh Jedi Survivor you know
uh people love to work with IPS it's
just bread and butter there's a reason
when Netflix is working for a new show
they're like what's going on League of
Legends what's going on cyberpunk what's
going on because they know those have
established IPS they're established an
audience they know they could get that
audience at least to watch that show can
they get more than just that audience
that's that's really the question
yeah
I do agree with what he said um at the
beginning of his super chatty we said um
like good games get ignored all the time
that is true there's a lot of good games
that just fly like I got ignored and
this generation pad last generation just
period
um so that you know that's true and I
guess Harry Potter being the IP that
instantly brought more eyes to the game
but they had to deliver on quality and
they did that so I'm gonna give them
credit for that
yeah so I mean anything you want to say
about that balloon
no I'm not like the IP thing is like I
completely grew dirt there it's like
sure the IP brings eyes to it but if it
was a crap game especially with the
controversy going on with it people
wouldn't have been as like a high on it
and they wouldn't be able to justify why
like they wouldn't have sold as many
copies it would just would have been bad
people would have talked [__] about it
and then they would have been like oh
there's this controversy surrounding it
so you're literally just buying it for
owning the people who don't want you to
buy it type of thing so yeah and they
they knew what they were getting it too
they knew what kind of response was
going to get and the sad part is these
are just a group of people that most
likely wb's like yo we got the Harry
Potter uh we got the Harry Potter IP we
want you to make a game and they're like
well it's not like they could tell them
no that's their job and people for some
reason people have this misconception
that if you're unhappy at a place you
just find another job like that easy
doesn't that never happens that way
especially you're in like a form of
corporate world like development
processes because you're working for
these multi million billion trillion
dollar companies
it's not easy especially if you get in
the bag back you know sometimes easy
deal dumb [__] if you getting if you
feel real comfortable at all like right
so yeah I get it I get it uh Christopher
Hart you're not being bullied okay you
don't have to talk in the chat if you
feel like the chat's coming out no the
first thing Chris said is game passes
for poor people so oh I didn't even see
that that's why I banned all of his all
15 of his accounts on my chat man the
mods
you lucky King's a fan of you you lucky
man sometimes you'd be saying stuff in
the chat though I'm like we gotta get
him up out of here then again people
have been impersonating Kristen for
heart a lot here lately yeah but I think
this is him
he's like it sounds just like something
is stupid
just realize that only poor people love
Xbox game best can you believe this no I
like it why you know I'm never mind I'm
not poor and I love Xbox game pass and
I'm poor and I love game pass so I think
it's loved by everybody
all right so yeah I think we're gonna uh
slowly uh pull our way out of here you
know what I want in the show is to go
around you know what's some games in
2023 that you guys are really excited
for I'm kind of curious to hear uh
people's opinions on this because I know
there's a lot of unique stuff coming out
this year and I'm just curious to see
what your guys uh looking forward to let
me get this time stamp in here for the
time step Mafia yeah we get that right
man yeah they I don't put it in there
they'll put me at Six Feet Under yeah
all right so what's what's games that
you guys are looking forward to we'll
start with the dirt
well you know um the obvious you know uh
you know rareforest star feel I'm
looking forward to hopefully hellblade
if it drops this year I'm looking
forward to Spider-Man 2
um
what's some other what's the multiplies
that schedule Oh atomic heart I'm
looking forward to that hopefully this
year yeah
I'm kind of curious that they're going
to give it to me
yeah um so there's um definitely a few
I'm trying to think of some more um
multiplies that was announced for this
year I'm trying to remember
I don't really remember Stella blade is
a game that kind of sparked my interest
a little bit but I don't know if I'll
buy day one
um but it looks interesting
um yeah I'm trying to figure some more
games I think I can't think of uh
you know oh Resident Evil 4 remake I am
hyped for that one like I told you
before I never finished Resident Evil 4
in the past never finished it I play out
I made it through halfway through the
game never finished it thought it was
good I just I don't know why I never
finished it back then in those days I
didn't finish a lot of games I'm
definitely looking forward to that one
because I love the Resident Evil 2 and
Resident Evil 3 remake love both of
those games I can't wait for four so
that's definitely on top of my list uh
I'm not looking forward to Zelda though
you say something he's right there
oh Alan Wake too also I'm a big Alloway
fan
I would have bet you Plum what's going
on in that head of yours man what you
looking forward to
2023 is already insane like my it's just
some already so many games coming my
back walls already massive but like
I mean all the main ones like Starfield
red fall uh Star Wars Jedi Survivor I'm
not looking forward to that yeah yeah
I'm looking forward to that Assassin's
Creed game or going back to like the
smaller one so Assassin's Creed Mirage
um
whoa long coming out on Game Pass that
looks pretty cool
Zelda obviously is always like probably
my in my top most anticipated games uh
Street Fighter 6 happy that's coming to
Xbox I'll be checking it on there
oh there's just there's tons of Diablo
I don't know there's so many games man
like there's so many games
back here you know what's funny yeah
because I do r r uh that's like TV
movies and stuff it's a stacked year in
movies too it's ridiculous like I don't
know what I'm gonna do I don't like I'm
a I'ma just roll up in the fetal
position and just cry all year like
there's just too much [__] going on for
me to do everything so I'm just gonna
get thrown to the size I'm sorry stuff
gonna have to be I'm gonna walk around
act like I don't know some of these
games like there's just not enough time
it's crazy it's crazy even right now
like my I've decided I'm gonna take
these games slower I'm not gonna try to
rush it because you know you play these
games you see everything coming out and
you get that feeling of like and then
you try to rush through it yeah and you
try to rush through it I'm like I can't
do this I'm just gonna enjoy it I'm
gonna enjoy Hogwarts I'm gonna just take
my time and I'll play the other ones
when I get to it yeah that's the best
way to do it man see that's why I'm not
rushing with hard works I'm just kind of
taking my time like I said I big Dead
Space where you make him want to be and
it made me want to play the part two and
part three and then I realized looking
at my achievements I said I thought I
finished part two I guess I didn't
finish it back in the 360 days so I'm
gonna finish that finish three and you
know maybe go to hard work but by that
time crazy before it's going to be out
so there's so many games bro so many
games it's ridiculous so I feel like we
it's it's good but we got issues
that's the show man uh you know let's
let's go over here to uh uh uh I'm Gonna
Make You spam you gotta put in that five
straight times yeah it's oh wait it
didn't it linked to like some Chinese or
YouTube page oh click on that one guys
don't click on that one let me say that
we see oh yeah it did
yeah
he has one sub he has one sub this guy
yeah it looks like the YouTube's messing
up again it's fine we about to get out
of here anyway just uh dirt put your
stuff in there too I don't know what's
wrong with YouTube here lately there we
go that's working yeah you guys are
ridiculous man
I don't know man
thanks for listening appreciate it look
at that spam man
I'm accidentally put in like three or
four times oh
I remember coming through uh you know
definitely go follow these gentlemen on
their channels I'll put it in the
description uh
stream looks horrible I don't know
what's going on uh that's a YouTube
issue I'm out anyway so I'll talk to you
guys later we'll see you next week peace